today we're playing jazz Lyon Beckett
it's a French game about climbing we are
all level four holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you
think I'd be good at playing this at
this time male that nail that no problem
okay so we need to get toasted
I assume we're going to the hairdryer
and I assume we can't touch anything on
the floor and I assumed the toilet it's
gonna be an awesome time let's plan out
our route
the walls are contaminated because like
old French people they're filthy and
disgusting I'm just kidding alright well
we're off to it's [ __ ] terrible start
there we go nothing will stop this loaf
from reaching its probe look at this
speed run
look at this speed run what is happening
what is happening I don't like this I
think I turned it on aah oh God
contamination wait I'm being toasted
right now I'm big toasted Wow
toast my other side baby aah Oh God
very bad multi-tape yen no wait
Paradis yeah like it toast to me baby
no no toast me more choice me more
toast me more turn
yeah are you [ __ ] my eyes out I
don't see how you can toast on a
radiator but what do I know about life
no touch it let's get on top of that
[ __ ] oh my god him I mean too toasted
what that was easy
oh my god I'm [ __ ] MLG day five let's
do it easy
what we're into Dempster
what kind of French person would waste a
perfectly fine well-adjusted intelligent
radioactive loaf what kind of sick world
we live in or people just throw away
bread oh god what do I do why do I go
alright well [ __ ] it it's fine it's fine
it's fine buddy there it is wait why are
we going where are we going
all right we're going all right why are
we going where we go right where you're
eating to get Rosh chainsaw oh oh oh oh
my god I'm scared I'm scared you've
scared me this game is terrifying
it's really dirty as [ __ ] here I don't
know how this is fine so yeah I guess
footballs are really a portal to a
different dimension it all makes sense
if really if you think about it
No
oh god oh god oh god ah this should hurt
a lot but since I have red superpowers
I'm fine I'm really fine
let's see how this one
in it she otto una chainsaw tato potato
Aaron a search button
so why isn't he not working well that
was the biggest letdown on my life a
chainsaw doesn't work why would they
bother putting a chainsaw if it doesn't
work oh my god this is aah Oh God
it should hurt a lot it does hurt a lot
Oh God all right you know what let's
just go with it yeah yeah baby
you thought you could defeat the
greatest bread champion in Sweden okay
there we go what do we do we need to
print turn up the heat how
maybe there's something up here what is
this oh my god there is something here
my god for a bread I'm pretty damn smart
and handsome did we do it
oh it's on now yay ah ah sweet sweet -
toaster ahh now return this is just like
sunbathing baby
yeah we got the D my favorite we done
diddly doing it coming soon
bam bam we completed everything in life
in life hope you enjoyed watching and
we'll play
pick a bra